Sandi's with us sandy is in Missouri
hey sandy how are you I've been better
but I'm glad I'm talking to you cool how
can I help today
I see I'm 68 husband a 70 and lost our
home to foreclosure for a con-artist
lawyer that doesn't have malpractice
insurance I moved out in an apartment
and I got about a hundred thousand in
savings I have a debt of 5,000 all my
credit cards are paid off and I don't
know where to go from here I'm sorry
yeah how long were you in that house 40
years how long have you been married
about 46 okay well when Sharon and I
went broke and lost everything
we weren't your age but we still know
the emotions one of the things it does
for you is it helps you instantly get a
firm grasp on what's real and what's
important things you thought were
important
turns out aren't maybe right Yeah right
like you guys got each other you got a
hundred thousand dollars you have a roof
over your head and you have food on the
table your heart is broken and you're
pretty pissed off and I don't blame you
for both but B you know you you really
do have a lot of blessings in your life
and that's kind of one of the things
Sharon and I did when we went broke you
didn't go broke but I mean you lost your
house and that's just kick your teeth in
emotionally something I understand so
what would I do from here 68 and 70 you
said right yes okay are either one of
you earning an income um we both are how
are you okay so what's your household
income about 95 Wow what are you guys do
well
husbands and customer service and then I
have my own business that I I work part
time out of my home time so you guys are
doing them well we have a we have a
pension that brings in 48 oh okay all
right so 48 is the pension and then
you're earning another 50 or so right
yeah well that's pretty cool
I've got some nice number I didn't
expect to hear so that's good all right
so we got $100,000 of your income we got
$100,000 in the bank we got five
thousand dollars in debt and we're
starting over on housing right right
okay well let's see if I were going to
walk you up our baby steps I would set
aside a percentage of this hundred
thousand as your emergency fund three to
six months of expenses
I would allocate some of the rest of it
to a down payment on a modest home that
you could get paid off really fast so
you live in where in Missouri and not
st. Louis st. Louis area okay yeah
Chesterfield mm-hmm so now that your
life has been readjusted to an apartment
what is a modest house price well I mean
I don't know it you know because of the
legal procedures I don't know if we have
to wait three years for foreclosure or
whether there's no history there of the
foreclosure because it wasn't done
properly so I don't know if I can go buy
a house next year when this lease is up
in June or if what was owed on you know
what was your owed on your home that was
foreclosed 245 okay and what was it
worth probably if we were able to keep
it up in the banks didn't there were
legal things in that that it would have
been worth 100,000 more so like 350 okay
but Ana's current state is probably
worth about what was owed on it okay
well no it's because it wasn't up ket
and waiting for all these years with
this
attorney that Kondos there are never
repairs made for a number of years okay
so what if we split what if we spent
three years adding to the hundred
thousand making ninety-five a year
living in very very conservatively and
we had a plan to buy a home in three
years and you were saying we're gonna
buy a hundred fifty thousand dollar
condo that we're gonna pay cash for did
we do that
that'd be fifty thousand befit save
fifty thousand dollars a year for three
years okay here's where I want to take
you to I want to take you to a paid-for
home for your retirement that stabilizes
a lot of things it gets it helps with
the scars of a foreclosure you don't
have that insecurity anymore you don't
have to fight with a house payment of
any kind even if it's a modest home and
I don't care if you move up later on
again but I want to get you into some
kind of a little modest condo or
something that we pay cash for in a few
years because that stabilizes the next
20 years of your life and then then we
can add to the hundred thousand for an
additional nest egg to stabilize your
life with as well okay but I saw I mean
if you guys can continue to bring in
ninety five thousand dollars a year for
five or six years we can do a lot with
that right the biggest problem you're
going to have is healing emotionally and
not using the rearview mirror but
instead using the windshield yeah that's
why I'm looking for help yeah it's just
when you get mad and you get hurt you
can spend all your time looking in the
rearview mirror and and sometimes that
even becomes bitterness and none of
those things going to be productive for
your future if you had a clean heart and
hadn't had your teeth kicked in and you
just call me up and said I make ninety
five thousand dollars a year I have a
hundred thousand what we do it's a lot
easier to run that math out forward
because you're not looking back and
you're not mad about this lawyer so I
want you to try to go an entire day and
not use con-artist lawyer in a sentence
which is really hard because you
really mad and I don't I don't blame you
but there's nothing to do about it I
mean he didn't have malpractice
insurance there's nothing to do about it
you've already put this to bed now
you've got to put it to bed don't you
okay don't you yeah yeah I know you're
hurting honey I know your heart is
broken but it's okay life does not
consist of the house we live in you walk
in there and give that 46-year man a hug
and go hey we started out when we were
broke Sharon I started out we were broke
when y'all start out where you broke um
no there's a history of other bad
lawyers so we were doing pretty good we
just lost it on when you got married you
weren't broke at 46 years no right well
I think you need to stay away from
lawyers I know that's why I'm calling
you
well I'm not a lawyer thank goodness but
right yeah but my point is when you
started out 46 years ago you and your
husband did you have anything I mean we
were in an apartment with your broken
yeah Sharon I start out in an apartment
eating off a card table and have any
money here we sit 38 years later blessed
and here you sit 46 years later blessed
lots of people don't have it they spent
the purse they don't get to finish the
story with the person they started with
and you're getting to finish the story
where the person you started with
story's not done yet
turn the page let's move to another
chapter that last chapter sucked it's
got to get better in the next chapter so
let's look forward and let's work
towards paint paying cash for a little
conservative modest condo and then let's
start saving money and building some
wealth and if you if you've done
something stupid or trust the wrong
people that makes you a human being
every one of us have done something
stupid and we've trusted the wrong
people and it's just there's just some
people out there that aren't good that's
sad
and they really are so you've learned
the lessons and you'll probably keep
learning some
I hope you don't learn anymore as
painful as that one but uh you'll get
there you're gonna be okay kiddo
windshield not rearview mirror
windshield not rearview mirror
windshield that's where the grace is
rearview mirror where the pain is
windshield not rearview mirror look into
the future don't live in the past this
is the Dave Ramsey show